I bet you like Gary you have like a
vinyl collection hmm I knew it not only
that I have vinyl in my office now
what do you do with it listen to the
wall if I can Gary with that vinyl makes
me mental you like music so much love
music but I'm not gonna go out of my way
two big pieces of vinyl but it's like I
know what this will sound like but it's
having a relationship with that muse
open it up you put it on the car is
actually moving that's the difference
I'm in a relationship you gotta clean
the record do you premia record i pre my
records over my head they said liquid
that you put on no Gary Prem's
Gary goes up to an attic like houses
which tells you what Mary doesn't want
any part so you go out there and you
specifically gonna go listen to music
something that are very excited about
like Springsteen or Broadway
I got a deluxe copy a box set of Santana
Abraxas do you ever like bring plantain
chips up there are things to snack I
know are you ever in the middle of
listening and there's no drawer for
snacks you don't do you ever lift the
stylus in the middle of it or go to
[Music]
label the records in any way we're doing
the Beatles it would start with say meet
the Beatles and end it whatever they're
okay everything's all together except
for soundtracks to be together too
we should go over there just to look at
it Rosanna welcome to tour it I will
play
and like do you have a special cabinet
to store the records in like a shelf
where she'll have shelving that I bought
a couple of years ago that are
specifically made for records is your
added climate-controlled because those
right I was gonna say temperature
control but do you keep your records at
a certain temperature yes I do
to be is fine hat and no he would is he
it's well bad for the inner sleeves
that's right they stick to the jacket
you don't have a vial I do have vinyl
not as slavish is Gary as they hit the
guys are saying to him a picture of
Gary's record room if we want to see it
it is chronologically listed some tiles
are all denial about color oh my god and
look he's got that collection got an
old-time tape recorder so what are you
doing there you got a reel-to-reel
8-track cassette player a reel-to-reel
player display your reel-to-reel yes I
use a brand reel to reels in private
foot was a private parts I owned it I
owned it to the movie and then I got it
back wow what a story I think there's
another book in this